[Music]
on this Friday night the Ukrainian
president's powerful message to Canada's
parliament Ukraine and Canada are the
same
we stand and we fight for Life the
additional Aid Canada is providing and
what zelinski says will happen if Russia
is allowed to win Moscow must lose once
and for all
New Revelations the surveillance and
intelligence alleged to be behind Canada
accusing India of murdering a BC man
another Canadian police officer killed
in the line of duty fatal shooting the
turn to Suburban Vancouver neighborhood
into a crime scene
plus crash call I'm sorry what happened
an ejected U.S military pilot a
surprised homeowner and a confused 9-1-1
dispatcher
global national with Donna Friesen
[Laughter]
he came to Canada looking for solidarity
and support and he got it Ukrainian
President Vladimir zelenski here to
address Parliament for the first time
since Russia's full-scale Invasion still
wearing his signature army green a
reminder that for more than a year and a
half he has led a nation at War
to see you here today in this chamber to
see so many proud and courageous
ukrainians here today after everything
you have all endured is a testament to
the commitment of your country
and the strength of your fight
Justice is not an empty word for Canada
Life and Justice must Prevail everywhere
in Ukraine and for all ukrainians
this Russian aggression must end with
our victory
yes
good evening and thanks for joining us
after stops in New York and Washington
where there were signs of fatigue about
the war zelenski was looking to Canada
for reassurance prime minister Justin
Trudeau told him Canada will stand by
Ukraine for as long as it takes our
chief political correspondent David
Aiken begins our coverage tonight
Applause of admiration and respect from
Canada's lawmakers and guests and from
the guest of honor expressions of
admiration and respect returned and you
are always on the bright side of History
thank you
Vladimir zielinski was referring to
Canada's contributions to Victory in
Europe through two world wars in the
Cold War but he said Canada's help is
needed now for another war in Europe and
we want to win
when we call on the World to support us
it is not just about an ordinary
conflict
it is about saving lives of millions of
people to that end Canada announced an
additional 650 million dollars in
military aid to Ukraine to be spent over
the next three years most of that will
be used to give Ukraine 50 armored
vehicles vehicles to be built in an
Ontario Factory Canada will also give
Ukraine 34 million dollars to help
small-scale farmers to help with
recovery efforts and to provide Mental
Health Services in Ukraine I know first
lady zelenska you are dedicated to the
work to address this in the House of
Commons the gallery was filled with some
of the 175
000 ukrainians who have found safety in
Canada after being forced to flee their
Homeland because of the war and most of
all I would like to thank you Canada for
the purely human thing
for making ukrainians feel at home
when they are here in Canada thank you
thank you Canada's Aid to Ukraine is now
moving to a longer term Focus moving
beyond the war to recovery and so
there's funds to help rebuild
infrastructure funds to help Ukraine
with democratic reform but Canada still
wants to make Russia pay for its
aggression and so Canada and Ukraine
will start talks to find ways to seize
hundreds of billions of dollars in
Russian assets in Europe and elsewhere
as compensation for the damage the
Russian government has caused Donna
David Aiken in Ottawa thank you in
Washington yesterday zielinski got a
commitment for another 325 million in
U.S military aid and some long-range
missiles that can strike targets as far
as 290 kilometers away well behind
Russian front lines Britain and France
have already supplied another long-range
missile the Storm Shadow and it was used
in Ukraine's latest missile attack on
Russian occupy Crimea the headquarters
of Russia's Black Sea Fleet and
Sebastopol was hit and last week the
missiles were used in another attack on
a Russian Shipyard without those weapons
especially from the U.S Ukraine could
not fight this war Eric Sorensen looks
at the challenges it is up against
Ukraine's counter-offensive is winning
back hard fought territory and some key
villages
but this is the hard truth of the war in
eastern Ukraine wretched fighting from
small trenches few gains and high
casualties on both sides
we hit them they hit us says this
Ukrainian Soldier
there are a lot of them he says too many
my fear it says this Ukrainian is that
Russians will get to my home
that is the reality the Russian military
still controls much of eastern Ukraine
the Russian troops extend all the way to
the border with Belarus but a thousand
kilometers of front lines are in
Ukrainian territory the Ukrainian
counter-offensive hope to punch through
and cut off Russian supply lines but the
Russians are dug in there are many lines
of Defense with tank trenches and
minefields and the Ukrainian gains in
blue have been limited and there are few
signs that this grinding standoff will
soon change the Russian strategy would
appear to be to sit on the defensive
uh wherever ukrainians out
and then over time convince them that
this is futile and also um I think
perhaps strategically perhaps more
important it's also to convince western
states that this is futile the national
Community must not allow Russia to get
away with this land grab at the U.N
Western allies one after another pledged
to maintain support for Ukraine if
Russia stops fighting there will be no
war
if Ukraine stops fighting there will be
no Ukraine but Poland has said it will
not send any more weapons to Ukraine
over a grain dispute and voices raising
questions about financing Ukraine are
growing louder in Washington we're very
concerned about accountability if
Ukraine doesn't make progress over the
next uh say 12 6 to 12 months I think
there are going to be there's going to
be additional pressure in the Western
World the ukrainians are counting on new
weapons and fighter planes to turn the
tide but Russia has announced that it's
increasing its military spending too and
it could go on for years and years and
years it's a match of political will at
some point uh political objectives need
to come into line with military reality
is for now the military reality is that
Russia and Ukraine both have sufficient
resources to fight on Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto
there is a developing story in British
Columbia tonight an RCMP officer has
been killed and at least two other
officers injured after a shooting in the
Vancouver suburb of Coquitlam Nita
Garcia is there nitu what do we know
about what happened
Donna the policing Community is in
mourning tonight and members from
multiple departments are now in A
procession which just departed from this
intersection behind me moments ago that
procession is being led by the ambulance
carrying the body of the officer who was
killed in the line of duty here this
morning RCMP have now identified the
officer who died as Constable Rick
O'Brien of the neighboring Ridge Meadows
RCMP Detachment police say he was part
of a team of officers who were executing
a search warrant on a residence in this
area officials say there was an
altercation with a man which resulted in
multiple officers being injured and the
man being shot the injured suspect a man
in his 20s is in hospital with
non-life-threatening injuries he was
known to police officials say one of the
injured officers was treated and
released from hospital and the other
officer is still in hospital with
non-life-threatening injuries Witnesses
report seeing an officer limping and
bleeding from a wound in the leg they
also described seeing a man in handcuffs
being taken away from the scene by
police
someone was taken away in ambulance and
they were doing chest compressions and
someone in handcuffs and his underwear
was taken away there was
um a guy on the stretcher and they were
giving him like chest compressions
this all started this morning when a
swath of police and paramedics warmed
this intersection in a busy area near a
shopping center multiple residential
condo buildings and restaurants around
10 o'clock and since then officials have
confirmed that there is no further risk
to the public Donna all right
BC Thanks new information is emerging
about what may be behind the assertion
by prime minister Trudeau that the
Indian government is linked to the
killing of a Canadian sick leader no
evidence has been revealed publicly but
as tariya Israel explains there are now
reports the intelligence is based on
surveillance of Indian diplomats in
Canada
the Indian High Commission in Ottawa
whatever was happening Behind These
Walls someone was trying to find out the
allegation linking India to the
assassination of Hardeep Singh ninja is
based on the surveillance of Indian
diplomats as first reported by CBC it
means that there's been you know ongoing
collection we call it against various
targets and uh probably pretty credible
Delhi claims it has not received
specific evidence
prime minister Justin Trudeau did not
answer when asked what Canada handed
over Canada has shared the credible
allegations
that I talked about on Monday with India
we did that many weeks ago
Canada wasn't the only one watching a
member of the five eyes also provided
Intelligence on India that's the
alliance including the U.S UK Australia
and New Zealand it does suggest it's not
just a Canadian perspective on it and
and Canada's due diligence in making
sure they've got the intelligence right
Delhi says the claim it had anything to
do with niger's murder is absurd and
accused Canada of Sheltering terrorists
it's not a very uh surprising
reaction by the Modi government because
Modi government has always used foreign
policy issues for his domestic
constituency and Western leaders are
ready to embrace India as a
counterweight to China the financial
times is reporting American President
Joe Biden brought up niger's murder with
Indian Prime Minister Narendra Modi at
the G20 but this political expert says
Biden has been reluctant to publicly
criticize about a range of issues
whether it is in terms of democratic
backsliding whether it is in terms of
treatment of religious minorities India
has remained silent on the latest
Revelation about the surveillance of
Indian diplomats in Canada the latest
development in a tumultuous week that's
included diplomatic expulsions travel
advisories and Visa suspensions all
against the backdrop of a murder
investigation
Taria esri Global News
Ottawa
Ontario Premier Doug Ford lost another
Minister from his government today the
third this month labor Minister Monty
McNaughton says he's stepping away from
politics to pursue a position in the
private sector Queen spark pure Chief
Colin Demello is following that while
Premier Doug Ford's summer of Scandal
just received another blow Monty
McNaughton the high-profile cabinet
minister in Premier Doug Ford's
government suddenly announced today that
he was going to be quitting politics
leaving in the days to come this is a
severe blow to Premier Doug Ford because
of what McNaughton represents he's been
seen as a highly successful cabinet
minister forged new relationships
between the conservative government here
in Ontario and labor unions so much so
that he's been credited as being one of
the instrumental pieces in the 2022
election helping Propel Dunford to an
even greater majority than he had in
2018. the big question though why now
critics of the Ford government say they
believe it's easy to see why McNaughton
would have resigned at the height of the
green belt Scandal because they believed
McNaughton wouldn't want the Greenbelt
Scandal stench sticking to him
especially given the fact that he might
one day want to run for the leader of
the progressive conservative party
McNaughton is denying all of that he
says this was his decision to make he
says he still supports the premier and
his decision has nothing to do with the
green belt but some Progressive
conservative insiders say for McNaughton
to resign now while the premier is so
vulnerable is nothing short of
treacherous
Donna Colin Demello in Toronto thanks
I'm Jeff sempel at a rally in Toronto
the last stop in the Ukrainian
president's Canadian tour where he's
expected to arrive in mere moments I'll
have the details live next
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski's
final stop on his quick trip to Canada
is downtown Toronto he's meeting with
Business Leaders as well as people from
the Ukrainian diaspora Jeff Semple is at
a rally tonight Jeff what's expected
there Donna this is the last stop in
Vladimir zielinski's Whirlwind tour of
Canada where he is expected to arrive at
this rally really at any moment and when
he does he'll be met by the Prime
Minister Deputy Prime Minister other
dignitaries as well as several hundred
members of Canada's large Ukrainian
diaspora who you can see there from all
walks of life 1.4 million people of
Ukrainian descent live in Canada and
that number has only grown through the
invasion of course almost 200 000
ukrainians fled their country after
Russia's full-scale Invasion have come
here and are now living in Canada under
that special Visa program many of them
here tonight as well I spoke with one of
them a woman a school teacher in Kiev
who actually taught one of Vladimir
zielinski's children in Kiev before she
fled that City following the invasion
and came here to Canada she says she's
glad to see him here tonight because she
hopes that his visit helps keep
attention focused on that conflict
a lot of people all do not want to talk
about this anymore and it's just it's
not the news for them anymore so and we
have to make sure that we keep it alive
and we have to talk to them what's
happening why is it happening
my students from Ukraine had
presentations to for Canadian students
here just to
talk to them and explain them their
feelings and what they've been through
and that's and it's I think it's
important to keep it alive
and Jeff there was a meeting with
Business Leaders it was private but we
know do we know what they were
discussing yeah Donna this was very much
a business trip for Vladimir zielinski
he's in Toronto so briefly and yet made
quite a bit of time to meet with
Canadian Business Leaders at a downtown
Toronto hotel the Royal York really
underscoring the importance of his
efforts not only to drum up more
Military Support but also financial aid
to help rebuild Ukraine up till now
Canada has given about five billion
dollars to that effort but more than 500
billion is going to be needed and of
course that number goes up every day
this war drags on all right Jeff sample
thank you
gold bars luxury cars envelopes of cash
ahead of powerful U.S senator is swept
up in a bribery scandal
[Music]
a U.S senator from New Jersey and his
wife have been indicted on corruption
charges Democratic senator Robert
Menendez and his wife are accused of
accepting lavish gifts from three
businessmen to secretly Aid the Egyptian
government investigators say in the
search of the couple's home they found
nearly five hundred thousand dollars in
cash stuffed into the pockets of clothes
in the couple's closets and in the
safety deposit boxes they also found
gold bars and a luxury vehicle it's the
second time the senator has been
indicted on bribery charges he denies
the accusations
we're getting a better understanding of
a puzzling series of events after a U.S
fighter pilot ejected from his F-35 over
South Carolina last weekend he landed in
a man's yard and that man called 9-1-1
I guess we gotta pilot our house and he
says he's not addicted so he addicted
from the plane so we just see if we
could get some ambulances I'm sorry what
happened uh we got a pilot in the house
has there been a report of an airplane
crash
I have not seen any
um come up yet
okay what part of the body was injured
ma'am I'm a pilot in the military
aircraft and I ejected
um so I just wrote a parachute down to
the ground can you please send an
ambulance
I'm sorry what happened they did send an
ambulance is 100 million dollar fighter
jet crashed on Sunday after what the U.S
Marine Corps said was a malfunction the
plane wasn't found until Monday after
the public was asked to be on the
lookout for it
a correction on a story We aired on July
25th and our coverage of the mass
protests over Israel's planned judicial
reforms we stated that nearly 7 million
Palestinians are living under Israeli
military occupation and Palestinian
territories including the West Bank
according to data from the U.N that
figure is closer to 4.8 million
next the story of one woman's love for a
little boy in Ukraine
[Music]
in Ukraine people are trying to live as
normal a life as possible while fighting
for their country for many ukrainians it
is another form of resistance as Crystal
gemancing Reports they're still finding
moments of joy in unlikely places
David is nearly three years old and like
many his age
he runs on a seemingly endless supply of
energy
this child really helps me uh to stay
stay alive 18 months ago it was David
fighting to stay alive he was brought to
Kiev by volunteers evacuating people
from crematorsk Olga faziaba recalls
seeing a social media post on telegram
asking for volunteers to watch over a
tiny boy in hospital I decided to visit
this uh this poor child to help him
and actually
when I saw him my heart my heart was
stopped in a moment Olga was also alone
her husband Max was away fighting in
eastern Ukraine the little soul
rekindled her spirit and she wanted to
do something for him so the couple
inquired about adoption
oh he's saying that our cat was
disappeared now he finds her
David Olga discovered was born in izum
region southeast of harkeefe a territory
only liberated by Ukraine last September
Olga says during intense fighting his
birth mother fled with his siblings he
was left with his father but somehow
ended up in crematorisk and later in
Kiev after months of searching his
biological mother was eventually located
and approved the couple's adoption
request I just want him to know the
truth a truth he'll understand in time
but for now the focus is on joyful happy
moments they're able to create even
while living through a war
Crystal commencing Global News London
and that is global national for this
Friday thanks for watching tonight's
your Canada is a moment from governor
general Mary Simon's meeting with
President zielinski earlier today she
taught him a new word
and she taught me
she taught me a word
from your mother tongue
ayuri Natan
she said the meaning of this word is
don't give up
don't give up stay strong Against All
Odds
and so
shall it beam
are you another
Canada are you not uh Ukraine slavo
crane